Do you agree that he's a person? The
Holy Spirit's a person.
>> No, I wouldn't say that he's a person. I
would say that it's the it's the spirit
or the soul of the Father. When I say
person, I mean an agent that has mind,
will, emotions, rationale.
>> Yeah, then then separate from the
Father. Not separate, but distinct.
>> Different from the Father, that's
separate, that's different.
>> No, it's not separate.
>> The Father has a will and the spirit has
a will. Is your body separate from you?
>> My soul is inside my physical body. So,
whenever I die, this physical body will
be here and my soul will go somewhere.
>> is your is your is your body separate
from your soul?
>> Well, right now physically, no. But
whenever I die, it will be. But you
understand that your soul is distinct or
different from your body, right?
Uh well, I'm I'm Catholic, uh
but that's that's still up in the air.
I'm waiting on a tribunal to happen from
a book that I wrote. We'll see how long
that lasts.
>> So, you affirm the Trinity and the deity
of Christ.
Uh well, that's that's what the that's
what the book was on. That was the
questions that I had and uh
so, the the the Trinity part is what
stumps me now. And and for example, uh
one of the things that I that I've seen
that that you do, you talked about the
the LSV Bible, where it's a literal
translation of the Hebrew and then you
use you use ver- verses like Job 35:10,
where it talks about the maker is plural
in that verse. Is that Is that your
Is that how you bring the Trinity into
the Old Testament? I don't think I've
used that Jud- Jer- Job
>> this from one of from one of your
podcasts. You was on somebody's podcast
and you were explaining this. You used
Job 35:10, Psalm 149:2 and Ecclesiastes
uh
uh 12:1, where you're talking about the
the the the the noun in those verbs,
when it's talking about makers or my
maker, it's it's plural in the Hebrew.
Okay. And so, you're you're saying that
that points to
uh the Old Testament version of the
Trinity. Uh well, I I believe that these
plural examples
are what we would expect if God is a is
is triune.
Um you know, so we will see him
referring to himself in the plural, see
him referring to himself in the
singular. I'm not saying that those
things alone like oh it prove oh that's
Trinity, but when we when we when we uh
look at how the scripture demonstrates
how there is multiple persons who
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> um interact with each other within the
Godhead,
um you know,
the two Yahwehs
um in Genesis, the spirit of Yahweh, and
then we see
the you know, God referred to as makers
and you know, all this kind of stuff in
the plural like that,
most highs, then yes, um these are
evidences.
>> but the but the question about those
verses specifically it it and and this
talks to the uh
the uh the grammar the grammar rules in
Hebrew because the the way that you
described it in the other videos is that
the because the noun is plural, that's
showing like what you just kind of
described is that it's talking in the
plurality of God, but the verbs in those
in in all of those examples that you
gave is singular. So in the Hebrew the
Hebrew rule for that is when the noun is
plural and the verb is singular, the
subject is singular.
So it's not pointing to what you're what
you're alluding to. What what rule is
that? The majesty.
What rule is that?
Uh that uh
oh, hang on. It's in it it's in all of
the uh
the Hebrew to uh the English to Hebrew
books. And my computer rebooted earlier
and and I lost all of my slides. I'm
trying to regenerate them right now.
Uh so okay, so are are you um are you
against the Trinity? Like you didn't you
you don't believe the Trinity is taught
in the Bible?
Well, okay, so that's the that's the
thing. So, the the beginning of my
Christianity
and and coming back to Christ is is is 3
years ago I would have argued until I
was blue in the face that it's the
Trinity. Father, Son, Holy Spirit, three
persons, one essence, the same argument
that any Trinity any any Trinitarian
would make. But then after actually
reading the Bible and trying to make
sense of it,
I it it's like the opposite. It's not a
Trinitarian worldview. And part of that
is because of verses like Isaiah 45 and
chapter 45 6 through 6 through 10 and
Isaiah 46 9 and 10 and Deuteronomy 32
36.
So, when you look at those, because this
is the Old Testament talking, it's the
Father saying He's the only one. So, you
can't incorporate the Son into that.
Where does the Son fit in? Yeah, so I
I'm I'm just I'm trying to like
understand where you're coming
[clears throat] from, okay? Okay. So,
you're saying that
the Bible does not teach the Trinity, it
teaches that the Father is God alone. Is
that right?
>> Yes. Yes, that's what I'm saying.
Okay.
So,
when when the scriptures do refer to,
let's say for example,
uh the age the angel of the Lord as
being Yahweh, where He claims to be the
God of Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob, how do
you reconcile that then? The angel of
the Lord being God. Well, so are you
talking about the Exodus whenever He
gives the whenever whenever God gives
the
the Torah to Moses on Mount Sinai?
Um before that. I'm talking about the
burning bush. I'm talking about um
um in Genesis with Jacob, you know, and
Abraham, the angel of the Lord comes up
and claims to be Yahweh. Says, "I'm
Yahweh.
I'm the God of your fathers, Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob." He says that to Moses
at the burning bush. Right. Yeah, and
that would
So, what is what is there to reconcile?
I mean, that would be the father
speaking directly to his creation. No,
but that's the angel of the Lord who's
not the father. He's sent by the father.
Well, that would be a Then then then the
only way that you can reconcile that
then would it would be a messenger.
It's either It's either the father or
it's a messenger that he sent, and this
would be the the same as the same as
Jesus or and and I've heard you use this
argument before or or debate against it
where when a king sends a messenger, the
messenger is speaking in the place of
the king, and then you ask the question,
"Does that mean that the the messenger
is the king?" And in that case, the
answer is no. The messenger is not the
king. Or in this case, the
the angel of the Lord would not be God
the father, but he would be acting on
the father's
uh with with all of the authority of the
father. Yeah, but he can't claim to be
the father. Right. Yeah, I I agree. I
agree. He cannot claim to be God the
father. Right. So, he's claiming to be
Yahweh. The angel of the Lord that he's
He doesn't say "D- This is what Yahweh
says." He comes and says, "I am Yahweh.
I'm the God of your fathers Abraham,
Isaac, and Jacob. Remove your sandals."
Which verse are we talking about
exactly? Yeah, so if we go to Exodus 3,
uh I'll put it on the screen so we can
all look at it together. If we go to
Exodus chapter 3, I am such a slow
typer. This is really insane.
But, I do be typing with my left hand
over here. That's why. So, for people
who always make fun of me. Okay.
[laughter]
All right. Oops, I'm not sharing my
screen. There we go. All right. So, the
Exodus chapter 3,
uh verse 2, it says,
"And the angel of Yahweh appeared to him
in a blazing fire from from the midst of
the bush.
And he [snorts] looked, and behold, the
bush was burning with fire, yet the bush
was not consumed. So, Moses said, 'I
must turn aside now and see this
marvelous sight, why the bush is not
burned up. And Yahweh saw that he turned
aside to look. So God called to him from
the midst of the bush and said Moses,
Moses. And he said, here I am.
Then he said, do not come near, remove
your sandals from your feet for the
place on which you stand is holy ground.
He also said he said also, I am the God
of your father, the God of Abraham, the
God of Isaac and the God of Jacob.
Then Moses hid his face for he was
afraid to look at God.
So it's Yahweh, uh the angel of Yahweh
comes to Moses
in the midst of the bush
and even cuz Moses is the author here,
even identifies the one who's in the
bush as God, as Yahweh looking at Moses
seeing that he turned aside and then
calling out to him from the bush. Okay,
so what am I reconciling?
So the angel of Yahweh here is claiming
to be Yahweh himself. Now, a mere
messenger can't do that. Obviously, this
would be blasphemy.
And we can't say this is agency because
that doesn't work with agency. Agency
cannot The agent cannot claim to be the
one who sent him.
Right? But this here
he's claiming to be Yahweh himself.
Okay, so then then who would who are you
saying the angel of
the angel of Yahweh is? Oh, that's
That's the second person of
the Trinity. That would be the
pre-incarnate Christ. Christ before he
took on flesh. Yes. And that's so it So
it would be Christ and not the Holy
Spirit? Not the Holy Spirit. It would be
distinct from the Holy Spirit. So the
angel The angel of Yahweh is Jesus
before he takes on flesh? Yes.
Yes, sir. Then who Then how Where does
the Where does the Holy Spirit come in?
Cuz he's the three persons, right? Yeah,
the Holy Spirit's there, too. The Holy
Spirit's there all the time. Like he's
there in Genesis 1 hovering over the
face of the deep, right? Hovering over
the waters. Obviously, that So you saw
it sounds like you you saw my debate
with Jacob Hanson and I give the
examples where the spirit is sent forth
and gives life and creates. Right?
Quoting Job and quoting Psalm 33. So,
the spirit is there always. The spirit
is there. The spirit even speaks, right?
The spirit speaks in in in 2 Samuel 23.
David says, "The spirit of Yahweh has
spoken. His word is on my tongue."
Talking about the spirit. Right. So, the
spirit's always there. The spirit's
always around doing doing doing doing
doing his thing.
>> [laughter]
>> Right. But,
yeah, I just wanted to show you like
that yes, there is another person uh
distinct from the Father who also claims
to be Yahweh.
Uh and and and that's with the spirit
but with also the angel of the angel of
Yahweh, too. Well, the the only the only
problem the only problem that I would
have with any of that is I mean, you
make a really good case and I'm not
saying that you don't have a good case.
Thank you.
>> the problem with that is that the
all of all of Jewish history doesn't
agree with you. That's not true. I mean,
that's the reason why that's the reason
why Christ was was uh put on the cross
because they said that he was
blasphemous. Well, but that was that was
only before Abraham was, I am. And they
were like, "Ah, it's blasphemy." And
they're ripping their
Because he's claiming to be what you say
he is, that he's the son of God or that
he's claiming to be God. So,
they they crucified him.
Yeah, but
>> believe that he was who he said he was.
Yeah, the devil said that's that There
it is right there. You hit it right on
the nail. They didn't believe who he
said he was. This doesn't mean that this
goes against Jewish history. This is
embedded in Jewish history. It's in the
scriptures. You just have these
disbelieving Jews.
Okay? Mhm. Then you have the other Jews
like his disciples, his apostles, they
believed. They worshipped him.
Right?
>> Oh, yeah. No, I don't I don't disagree
with that because all of the apostles
and the whole movement is is how you
split Judaism. Cuz everybody that that
he talked to, well, until he started
talking to the uh
uh
uh the lay people, but but the his whole
following started off from Jews. I don't
disagree with that.
So, I mean, you split that in half.
Right. So, so now the question is really
who which which side which split is in
line with the scriptures from before?
Right. So, okay.
>> the apostles or is it the Pharisees?
>> There you go. You're hitting the You're
hitting the nail on the head here, and
that's what I That's kind of what I
wanted to talk about is is the way that
because what I'm talking about is the
grammar of of Hebrew and how grammar
works and how the
Hebrew language is written. So,
whenever you look at the Old Testament,
if if if if it if it was meant to mean a
trinity, it could have been written that
way. And it's not.
>> it was. No, there's no verse There's no
verse in the Old Testament or in the New
Testament that proclaims a trinity.
Well, all right. Wait. Are you saying
where it the word trinity is there? No,
not just that the word trinity is there.
The The grammar doesn't allow it.
Brother, the So,
I I just I just showed you I just showed
you where you have another person other
than the Father
who is claiming to be Yahweh.
And and and it ain't blasphemy.
So, it's either the angel of Yahweh is
The angel of Yahweh meaning so, he's
distinct from the person who is who
sends him, but he's also clearly Yahweh.
Either he's committing blasphemy or he's
another person of the Godhead. Or Or the
angel of Yahweh then would be the Holy
Spirit.
>> Okay. So, let
Because I don't think the Holy Spirit is
a third person. I think the Holy Spirit
is is the actual spirit of Like you have
a soul, I have a soul. I would say that
the the Holy Spirit is the soul of God
the Father. I I I I see, but but here
here's the problem because if you're
saying that the Holy Spirit is not a
person, but you're saying that the Holy
Spirit is the angel of Yahweh,
then you have to say the Holy Spirit is
a person cuz the angel of Yahweh is a
person. He's speaking, he's
communicating, he's making decisions,
he's sending out, he's appointing.
That's personhood. You know what I'm
saying? But he's not speaking his own
words, right?
He is. He's saying, "I am He's saying,
"I am I am Yahweh. I'm the God of your
fathers." That Yeah, that's what he's
told to say. But that was your argument
just a minute ago with the other guest
from uh
from uh John 16 or John 13 six six
whatever it was. John 16:13. But but
here here's the point that But that
proves personhood. If I if I tell you
what to say, Mhm. that means that you
have rationale to be able to do what I
just told you to do.
Right. I can't I can't tell my Look, I
can tell my table to speak my desk right
now. I Hey, table, tell tell this
brother Benjamin that he's a really
handsome brother. We can't hear nothing.
It's an inanimate object, right? Even
though I told him what to say told him
what to say, he can't speak cuz it's
it's inanimate. But so for the spirit to
be told what to say and he does it, that
shows rationale. It shows personhood.
Okay? So the spirit is not just some
force.
I'm not just applying that to the
spirit. I apply that to Jesus, too,
because
>> Sure, of course. with his own
words is all of the words that I give
you are not my words, are the words the
father gave me. No, brother. No No
worries. No worries. All
All you're demon- All you're
demonstrating is that the Father and the
Spirit's I'm sorry, that the Spirit and
the Son submit to the Father. That's all
you're showing. That these are distinct
persons. They submit to him. Exactly.
Okay. Okay, so but now So we see that
they are these are distinct persons who
submit to the Father. Yep. But now, what
about their essence? What about their
nature? We're saying that their nature
is divine. I agree that Jesus is a
distinct person, but I don't think that
the spirit I still don't think the
spirit is a distinct distinct person for
for one specific reason. This is why.
Because
>> Wait, wait, before we get to that,
brother, cuz I cuz I don't want us to
get too far like I want us to be
focused. Let's deal with the personhood
of the spirit later.
Let's deal with whether or not God is
multi-personal first. Okay?
>> So, the angel of Yahweh, we know we
clearly see that the angel of Yahweh is
has personhood, right? He has rationale.
I agree.
So, he is a person and he is distinct
from the person who sends him, right?
Cuz he's being sent. He's the angel of,
the messenger of Yahweh.
See, that's where we disagree.
Because it's God the Father sending his
his spirit. When I And And Jesus did
this with the apostles. He breathed the
spirit upon the apostles and then they
went out and did all the things that
Jesus did. So, Jesus is sharing
the spirit that he gets from the Father
with the apostles. And then he tells the
apostles to go minister and do all the
things that he just did. Heal the sick,
raise the dead, all of that. Okay. Um
let's let's break this down like
in very minute ways. What does it mean
to be the angel of Yahweh? Well, wait a
second. The angel of Yahweh
>> agree
the spirit
>> agree Would you agree that Would you
agree Would you agree that that mean
that that shows a distinction between
the angel
and
Yahweh who sends the angel or messenger?
>> Because it's the spirit If I say If If I
say I'm the the son of my father, that
means that shows that there's a
distinction between the son and the
father who's he's the son of, right?
Right. If I say
um
the brother of, you know, Benjamin. Mhm.
That shows a distinction between the
brother and Benjamin who this brother is
the brother of, right?
>> Mhm. Angel of Yahweh shows that there's
Yeah, the angel/messenger
Mhm. who is distinct from
Yahweh, the person who sends him.
Cuz he's the angel of Yahweh.
Right?
>> Yeah, I will I'll tell you this. I will
I will accept that if you will accept
that that when when Jesus was baptized,
the spirit came down like a dove. So,
that's distinction where the spirit of
God is separate from God the Father.
It's the same thing. And that's separate
but distinct. I'm with you. The spirit
descends. And so, that shows that the
spirit is distinct from the Father and
>> of Christ, right? Okay.
So, there we understand the
distinctions. Okay.
>> Right.
So, the angel of Yahweh The angel of
Yahweh
is a person who is distinct from the
Father who sent him, right? Now, this
person who's not the Father,
but he's the messenger, the angel,
claims to be Yahweh himself, claims to
be God himself, Mhm. while also being
distinct from the Father. So, what you
have here is you have two persons at
least for now. Mhm. We have two persons
who are identified as Yahweh. We have
the Father who's identified as Yahweh,
and we have the messenger who the Father
sends who is identified as Yahweh as
well. Yes, I agree. So, this shows, at
least for now, that Yahweh is at least
two persons. It shows No, I I what I'm
agreeing on is that it shows that
there's two distinct things, and one of
the things can be the can be the the
spirit of Yahweh the spirit of God. Just
like in just like in the anointing of
Christ, the spirit descends upon Christ.
That's what I'm agreeing to. And we're
not talking about the spirit. We're
talking We're not We're not talking
about the spirit. We're talking about
>> the Lord is the spirit.
>> Okay. And we [clears throat] got the to
the point where the angel of the Lord is
distinct from the one who sent him,
right? Yes, I agree. Okay. So, these are
two persons who are identified as
Yahweh.
Right?
Yes.
Okay. So Yahweh for net where where
we're at right now, Yahweh is at least
two persons. Okay. So right now
Benjamin,
we're binitarians right now.
Yep.
>> Now I'm trying to convince you of a
third. Right.
>> Okay?
So I'm going to show you
that the angel of the Lord is
specifically Jesus because we we agree
that the spirit is distinct from Jesus,
right? Jesus is not the Holy Spirit,
right?
Right, yeah. Because the Holy Spirit is
what anointed Christ in the baptism.
Exactly. So the Holy Spirit and Jesus
are two distinct they're two two
distinct persons. Okay. So
I'm going to show you that Jesus is the
angel of the Lord. I'm going to show you
that.
Okay?
Go to Jude well I'll pull it up actually
cuz we got I got the big screen, so we
can go through this together. We're
going to go to Jude, all right. And I'll
have Jude there. And then what do I want
here? I want You said Jude, right?
Yep, Jude.
We're going to look at Jude and then
we're going to look at
uh
We're going to look at Exodus. Where is
my Where are my Bible study notes in
here? We're going to look at Oh man, I
don't got my Exodus notes in here. Let
me see. Sorry guys, give me 1 second.
Okay. All right. Exodus
um
Guys, what's the passage where the
angel of the Lord comes in the pillar
and saves the people of Egypt? The
angel's promise, is that what you're
talking about? Behold, I send an angel
before thee. Exodus 23.
>> one. That's that's 23. The specific one
I want to look at is when he saves them
from Egypt. Comes in there.
The glory of God appears. Let's see. Is
it 13? Right, Exodus 14 or something
like that. It's 13 to 16 or something
like that. All right, let me see. I
think it's Exodus Let's go to Exodus 14
real quick. Make sure you guys hit the
like button, y'all while while we're
doing this while we're getting through
this. Make sure y'all hit the like
button. My Oh, shush, shush. All right,
yes, there we go. All right, in Exodus
chapter 14, verse number 19.
Verse number 19, I'll put it on the
screen. So, we have it on the right
side, it says,
"Then the angel of God, who was going
before the host of Israel, moved and
went behind them.
And the pillar of cloud moved from
before them and stood behind them,
coming between the host of Egypt and the
host of Israel.
And there was a cloud and the darkness
and it lit up the night without one
coming near the other all night."
So, we see that the angel of the Lord is
there saving the Israelites from the
Egyptians, right? Now, watch what it
says here in Jude 5. I'm sorry, Jude
chapter 1. Well, there's only one. But,
verse 5, it says, "Now, I want to remind
you, though you know all things, that
Jesus, having once saved a people out of
the land of Egypt,
subsequently destroyed those who did not
believe." Jude says it was Jesus who was
there saving the Israelites out of the
land of Egypt. When you read Exodus, it
says it was the angel of the Lord doing
it. You put two and two together,
you see that the scripture is pretty
clear that Jesus is the angel of the
Lord. The angel of the Lord is the
pre-incarnate Christ. Jude chapter 1
verse 5. There's only one chapter in
Jude, but so yeah, Jude verse 5.
>> Jude 5? Yep. So, it says, wait. So,
what's your what's your argument there
for Jude 5 then? Put him put you in
remembrance through though you once knew
this, how the
how that the Lord,
having saved the people out of the land
of Egypt, afterward destroyed
>> your your says the Lord, huh? Yeah.
That's okay.
So, the earliest manuscripts say Jesus.
I've have problem with the Lord though.
That's okay. Why? Because in verse four
tells you who the Lord is. Read verse
four and the end read verse five
together. For there are certain men
crept in unawareness who were before
of old ordained to this
condemnation, ungodly men turning the
grace of our God into
lasciviousness and denying the only Lord
God and our Lord Jesus Christ. So, it's
Lord God and our Lord Jesus Christ.
>> Actually, no. No, it's not Lord God. No,
it's it's our only
>> it right here in our I I I know what
you're reading. That is a terrible
translation. This is the King James
Bible.
Yeah, that it it butchered that. This is
what it actually says in the Greek,
brother. Let me show you. Um
Jude Jude. Let me show you what it says
in the Greek. That that man, that was a
butchering.
What in the world? Look, it says So,
here's here's Are you able to see it? I
don't know, it might be small. Do I need
to enlarge it? Yeah, let me No, I got my
screen is small. There you go. Okay.
And I don't read I don't read Greek.
It's okay. Luck Luckily, they they did
the transliteration for us and stuff. So
>> two languages, English and bad English.
I'm only good at one. That's all right.
So, look, it says came in stealthily and
has the Greek right above it, right? So,
I I'm not going to want to try to
pronounce that stuff, but you get the
picture.
Came in stealthily
for certain men
those long ago have been designated unto
this condemnation
ungodly ones.
Um the the uh the
the uh the God of us grace changing into
Oh, they're changing the grace of the
only of the God of us into sensuality.
And the only master and Lord of us,
Jesus Christ, denying. Denying the only
master and Lord of us, Jesus Christ.
So, it's not the
Lord and God and then Lord of us, Jesus
Christ. No, it's Kyrios ton monon and
the only master
and Lord of us, Jesus Christ, they are
denying. Now, see, right here, I'm going
to I'm going to extend an olive branch
because I'm I know that I'm infallible.
So, I will admit that that this this is
something that I've never looked at
before.
Uh sure, yeah. So, right now, I'm taking
your word for it and according to your
word and I'm reading it with you on
screen and I haven't done my research.
So, so right now, what you're saying
actually makes sense. But, whenever the
way that it says this, uh
our master and Lord or or Lord of us,
that's a title that God gave to Jesus
anyway. So, I don't have a problem with
that.
Right. So, the the point is is that so,
even if I were to go with, let's say, um
the the variant reading that has Lord in
verse 5 instead of Jesus, where it says,
uh it was Jesus who saved the people,
but it says, it was the Lord who saved
the people out of the land of Egypt. The
reason why I I
I'm okay with granting even the reading
of Lord there in verse 5 is because
verse 4 told us who the Lord is. It says
the Lord is Jesus Christ.
>> disagree that it could be Jesus. Right.
But, the the distinction and see, I
don't even say I don't I don't even
disagree that Jesus
existed spiritually like how you
describe him. He was before the earth
and all that other stuff.
Right. I agree with that.
I agree with that. What I disagree with
is that he is equal to God the Father.
Well, so now, here's the thing. So, if
Christ is our only master and Lord and
he's the one who saved the people out of
the land of Egypt Mhm. and obviously, we
see we go back in Exodus and it's and
it's saying that it was the angel of the
Lord who saved them.
Mhm. Put two and two together, the angel
of the Lord is the pre-incarnate Christ
at work. That's who Christ was before he
took on flesh. You get what I'm saying?
And so, since that is Christ before he
took on flesh, Christ as the angel of
the Lord in Exodus
>> Yahweh. is claiming to be Yahweh. Mhm.
Okay.
I I Yeah, I see I see the connection
that you made there. I've never seen
that connection before.
Praise God. Praise God.
And so now, this is what we show. So,
since we know that the angel of the Lord
is Jesus, so now we know that he's not
the spirit. The Holy Spirit is a is
distinct person.
So, you have the Father, you have the
Son  the angel of the Lord, and
you have the Spirit. There's your
Trinity in the Old Testament.
>> Well, the only the only problem with the
Trinity, the only problem with making
the the the spirit
a person, this is what I was going to
say earlier, now that we've finished
that,
uh is the is the the talk of the throne
rooms. So, whenever whenever you in the
second coming
or or the second earth, you have the
throne room. So, you have the the Father
sitting on the on high, and then Christ
sitting at the right hand of the Father.
Where's the Holy Spirit? There's only
two thrones. Well, that that doesn't Let
let let's even grant that the Holy
Spirit is not sitting on a throne.
Right.
>> Cuz you you don't you don't have a a
verse that explicitly says that, sure.
That doesn't negate his his personhood.
It doesn't mean that he's not a person,
you know? He just he's doing something
else. He has another role, you know what
I'm saying? But
>> and I'm not saying that he's not divine
and doesn't have all the power and the
I'm saying that he's the I'm saying that
he's the I'm saying that he's the I'm
saying that he's the I'm saying that
he's the Yeah, I'm saying that he's the
soul like your soul you have a soul and
I have a soul that he's the soul of the
Father.
It's not a person.
Well, so now notice
>> So, notice this. So, watch this. If we
go to go to John 7.
Uh-huh. And uh And and John.
Yeah. This is
>> [laughter]
>> This is where I kind of make I kind of
understand. Yeah. John 7.
Go to John 7, man.
And go to verse uh we'll do verse we'll
do 37 to 39. 37 to 39. And then we'll
we'll parallel that with Revelation 22.
Which you're talking about the throne.
Okay. Revelation 22:1.
I like I like Revelation. Revelation
Revelation is is a beautiful thing.
>> the stuff I'm waiting on. That's hey.
>> [laughter]
>> Bring that on. I'm ready. That's right.
Okay.
So John 7, we'll start at verse 37 and
read up to 39. And then we'll parallel
this with Revelation 22:1. Okay? All
right. So verse 37 it says,
"Now on the last day, the great day of
the feast, Jesus stood and cried out
saying,
if anyone is thirsty, let him come to me
and drink. He who believes in me, as the
scripture said, from his innermost being
will flow rivers of living water. But
this he spoke of the spirit, whom those
who he who believed in him were going to
receive, for the spirit was not yet
given because Jesus was not yet
glorified."
So the
flowing of the rivers of living water,
the rivers of living water
is the spirit, the Holy Spirit. Right?
>> Before we Before you go on, the the
glorified part there is Does that mean
Does that mean he hadn't been crucified
yet? Is that what this is talking about?
>> Yeah, he hadn't been crucified and
resurrected yet. Okay. So this is all
before the the crucifixion and stuff.
>> Right. So he says that the spirit It
says that the spirit is the rivers of
living water, right?
Now, go to
Revelation 22:1. You I don't know if you
already have that ready. Yeah, and he
and he showed me a
pure river of water of life, clear as
crystal, proceeding out of the throne of
God and of the Lamb.
Yep. So you have here, you have the
river of liv- of the water of life, the
river of living water, Mhm. flowing from
the throne of God and the lamb. So, here
when you parallel the two, you see we
see the Father, who's God, and Jesus
Christ is the lamb. Mhm. The spirit is
there. He's flowing from their throne.
He Yeah, it flows from the Father
through the Son into creation. That's
right. Yeah, I don't disagree with that.
Good. So, this
>> That's how all of creation was made.
Well, exactly. So, so what this proves
as cuz you already you you you said it
you you you agree that the spirit has
all power and has these attributes,
right? You It's just his personhood that
you have a problem with.
>> Yeah, no, I don't have a problem with
that. Yeah. Good. So, That he's part of
the Father.
So, we have we we understand the
divinity of the spirit. Now, what we
need to demonstrate is
the dis- the personhood of the spirit.
That the Holy Spirit has rationale.
He he he he speaks. He he has he has
communion. He approves of things. He um
makes decisions.
Right? That's what I'm going to show you
right now, okay? Does he make decisions
autonomously outside the will of the
Father? Well, no. So,
not even Jesus makes decisions out of
the will of the Father. They all they're
all in complete unison.
The point is though is that they make
decisions. That the fact that they can
make decisions shows that shows they
they have personhood. They have
rationale. Right? But none of the
decisions they ever make is out of the
will of the Father. They are in perfect
unison together. So, which one So,
what's the hierarchy of the of the
Trinity then? So, you would have you
have the Father as as the fountainhead
or the source of the essence. Mhm. And
you have the Son who's begotten from the
Father's essence, and you have the
Spirit who proceeds from the Father's
essence. Mhm. So, the Father is the
source of the divine essence. He's the
He's the source of the divine nature,
right? And he communicates this nature
and the essence to the Son and the and
the Spirit. Right.
>> Okay. So, does the Spirit have a will?
Yes. But here's here's the thing. So,
your your your will, your mind, these
are all properties of your essence, your
nature. So, because the spirit because
the Father
and the Son and the Spirit because they
share the same nature, the same essence,
right? Means that they also share the
same will and mind.
They're They're not separate in that
way. The The cuz you cuz you're bringing
in you're bringing in the 4th century
classical Greek
to the conversation and when that's not
in the that's not in the Bible. It is.
No, the the Koine
is not The Koine Greek does not include
any of the essence talk. That's all
classical Greek. It It So, here's the
thing. It It does. The The The The
scripture talks about the divine nature.
You You have it You have the divine
nature mentioned in I think it's 1 Peter
where it mentions the divine nature. Um
Um you have in Hebrews 1:3, you have
hypostasis is used in referring to Jesus
having being the exact imprint of the
Father's nature.
Right? And so
you know, what what you have with the
church fathers and and and the the the
early theologians is they're
they're working this theology out that
they're seeing in the Bible, bro. They
have the Bible, they have these concepts
in the Bible and they're working those
out. They're fleshing those out. That's
That's what we're seeing. Okay. Oh, no,
no, no, I understand what you're saying
there. And see, I agree with you to an
extent and this is the reason why I
disagree with you here, okay? And this
is This goes back to Deuteronomy 4:2.
Don't add to and don't take away. And
the reason why that's important is
because what you just described is
we're talking about the the
philosophical
metaphysics of classical Greek versus
Koine Greek, right?
No, Koine Greek is just a language,
brother.
>> Right, but but it doesn't
>> a
It's not a philosophy.
>> It's the general Greek that's used in
the market. So, it doesn't include it
doesn't include the philosophical stuff.
No, no, if you're talking about Greek as
a language you're just talking about
Greek as a language. Right, right.
Whenever you want whenever you want the
philos- the the philosophy side of it,
the essence and the oneness of the same,
you know, all that stuff, that comes
from the classical Greek.
Okay? So, so, no, so hold on, let me No,
no, hang on. The problem is is when they
wrote the old the New Testament, the the
Greek the the the classical and the
Koine Greek was available. So, had they
wanted it to say that, it would have
been it would be unambiguous. Do you
believe that God is Do you believe that
God is omnipotent? Omnipotent means all
powerful. Yeah, oh, yeah. Okay. Is the
word omnipotent in the Bible? I'm going
to I'm going to say that it's not. It's
not. It's not. Cuz I've heard your
arguments on this. I mean, I already
know where you're going with it.
You know where I'm going with it. So,
these exact words do not have to be
found in the Bible for the Bible or for
these words to be in line with the
Bible's concepts. No, I mean, I No,
look, I agree with you. That's what I'm
saying. I agree with you. And but I do.
Yes, I do. I I completely agree with
you. And the reason why we disagree for
the for the perfect example is John 1:1.
Because John 1:1, the translation is in
the beginning was the word and the word
was with God and the word was God. But,
that's not what it says. That's exactly
what it says. Or or if you want to flip
it around in the Greek, and God was the
word. No. Okay, bro. So,
That's not what it says. Okay, well,
let's let's get let's get to that in a
second.
Let's get to that in a second. Let's get
to that in a second. The personhood of
the Holy Spirit. Well, but the point is
is that if they wanted it to say that,
there's four different ways he could
have written it.
And three of the ways could have
translated the way that you want it to
say. But, he purposely chose the only
way that can't translate that way. Okay,
brother. That verse actually says, "In
the beginning was the word and the word
was with God and the word was divine."
It says God. All right. Do me this
favor. Go to Acts 13 verse 2. So did you
give up on John 1:1? Well, that wasn't
what we were talking about. That's a
rab- that's a rabbit trail. That's
unimportant right now. Okay.
Acts what what was it?
13 verse 2. Okay. Let me give you a
couple. Acts 13
Acts 13 verse 2.
I'll put the verses on the screen, too,
so we can look at it. So just just to
save time. Okay. I got it right here.
All right.
Acts 13 verse 2. Go ahead and read it,
brother. As they ministered to the Lord
and sat and fasted, the Holy the Holy
Ghost said, "Separate
separate me
Barnabas and Saul for that work
whereunto I have called them." So you
have the Holy Spirit speaking to the
elders of the church saying, "Set apart
for me Barnabas and Saul for the work to
which I have called them, right?" The
Holy Spirit speaking. It says the Holy
Spirit said this, right? So we see that
the Holy Spirit one is speaking himself.
He says, "Set apart for me." I mean,
he's mean he's he's set the he's saying,
"Hey, do this for me." So he's
self-aware.
He's calls out Barnabas and Saul
specifically.
So he's making decisions. "For the work
to which I have called them." So he
appointed them job. He gave them
a an appointed them missions. Gave them
a job to do. So the Holy Spirit is
self-aware. He's speaking.
He's making decisions. He has a will.
Right? This is what it's showing here of
the Holy Spirit. He's the one doing
this. Now, watch this. In Acts 15 verse
27 and 28, watch what it says here.
It says, "Therefore, we have sent Judas
and Silas, and they themselves will
report the same things by word of mouth.
For it seemed good to the Holy Spirit
and to us
to lay upon you no greater burden than
these essentials." So here we have the
Holy Spirit
is approving of things, just like how
you have the apostles who are also
persons
giving approval.
He says, "It seemed good to the Holy
Spirit and to us." Inanimate objects or
is just
a soul or spirit can't can't approve of
things. It can't seem good to this, you
know, to to an inanimate thing. But the
Holy Spirit has personhood.
That's why he can approve these. That's
why things can seem good to him or not
good, you know, he can approve or
disapprove of things.
Right? And now here's one one last one.
Watch this. Talking about giving the
spiritual gifts. This is 1 Corinthians
12:11. It says, "But one and the same
spirit works all these things,
dis- distributing to each one
individually just as he wills." So, the
Holy Spirit is giving out the spiritual
gifts as he wills, as he sees fit. So,
we see the Holy Spirit has a will. He
has He has a will. He has mind to think
and to make decisions. He appoints. He
approves of things. Things seem good to
him. He is a person, okay? So, he's a
person who's distinct from the Son
and the Father while sharing the same
divine essence as the as as the Father
and Son.
Yeah, and see I don't disagree that
Well, I do I do disagree that that he's
it's the That that is the spirit of the
Father. And you say you say that he can
approve and disapprove of things. He's
the spirit of Christ, too. He has that
authority. Christ has that authority
also. But then so do the apostles after
Jesus gives them the the Holy Spirit. He
breathes the Holy Spirit onto the
apostles. And not only can they can they
do the miracles that Jesus did, he also
tells them to go and forgive sins. And
whoever sins are forgiven shall be
forgiven.
And whoever sins
>> Yeah, yeah, but there's no contention
there. So, so the the point is is that
the Holy Spirit has personhood. That
he's making decisions. He has a will. It
The scripture blatantly said he has a
will. He gives the spiritual gifts to
whoever he wills, just as he wills. He
said, "Set apart for me Saul and
Barnabas to the work to which I have
called them."
It seemed good to the Holy Spirit and to
us to give you these essentials.
Right? So, all of we're seeing very
clearly that the Holy Spirit is a is a
person.
He's not He's not just a
um
like an inanimate power that God uses
and Jesus uses. He's He's a person who
empowers the believers.
He's the He's the soul of of the Father.
I don't disagree.
So, you agree that do you So, you agree
then that the Holy Spirit
is a person? I agree that the Holy
Spirit is is the soul of the Father and
that he shares that freely. This is what
he shares with everybody. But do you Do
you agree that the spirit is a person?
Well, Jesus is filled with filled with
the Holy Spirit without measure, right?
Yeah, but do you Do you agree that that
he's a person? The Holy Spirit's a
person. No, I wouldn't say that he's a
person. I would say that it's the it's
the spirit or the soul of the Father
that he can share with with his creation
as he sees fit. All right, one more
thing. When I say person, I mean an
agent that has mind, will, emotions,
rationale. That's what I mean when I say
person. You understand what
>> from from the Father? Say that again?
That has autonomy from from the Father?
That has autonomy from the Father? Yeah,
that that's separate from the Father.
Not separate, but distinct, different.
He's different from the Father.
Different from the Father? That's
separate. That's different.
>> No, it's not separate.
>> The Father has a will and the Spirit has
a will. Are you Is your Is your body
separate from you?
Is my body separate? What do you mean?
Are you your body? Are you your physical
body? My soul is inside my physical
body. So, whenever I die, this physical
body will be here and my soul will go
somewhere else.
>> is your Is your Is your body separate
from your soul? Well, right now
physically, no. But whenever I die, it
will be.
All right, so but you understand that
your soul is distinct or different from
your body, right? Yeah.
So you can have something that is
distinct but not separate, right? So
your soul and your body are distinct but
they're not separate.
>> body don't have two separate wills. No,
I know. I'm just giving you I'm just
showing you the principle
that you can have two things be distinct
yet not separate. Right, yeah, I agree
with that.
>> good. So what I'm saying is is that the
spirit Mhm.
>> is distinct from the Father, not
separate from the Father. He's the
spirit of the Father. He can't be
separate from him.
But he is distinct, i.e. he is the
spirit of the Father. He's He proceeds
from the Father. The Father pours out
the spirit, right?
>> I agree with that. Okay. So now, there's
a distinction between the Father and the
spirit, not a separation.
And what we see here is that the spirit
is a person with mind, will, emotions,
approval,
right? Self-awareness, rationale.
We see that the Holy Spirit has those
qualities, which means that the Holy
Spirit is a person. But you haven't
shown where the where that is separate
from the Father. Yeah, we know that the
Son is separate from the Father in will.
That's John 6:38. The there
You know, I I
I'm arrested here, my brother. I'm
arrested here. I I done
pretty much done all I can. This was a
really good conversation. This was a
really good conversation.
Um please look back at this port part of
the discussion on what I'm explaining
and breaking down and and just review
it, go over it again, and you could
definitely come back and we could talk
again. I need to give somebody else a
chance, okay? Okay. Yeah, hey, thank you
for having me on. You're a wonderful
person.
Uh I know we don't we don't agree, but I
love talking to you and I'd love to be
back.
Yes, sir. God bless you, man. Take care,
okay? God bless you.
Peace.